épisodes précédents le gouvernement
juppé avait mis sur les rails la
privatisation de thomson et la fusion
aérospatiale d'assaut devant déboucher
là aussi sur une climatisation de
l'ensemble
aujourd'hui au bourget lionel jospin se
retrouvaient encadrer des deux
principaux intéressés les pdg yves
michaud et serge dassault il donc à
cette question mais les réponses
précises ne sont pas venus on en est
resté aux grands principes les
nécessaires regroupement dans les
industries de défense sont restés à
l'étude ces dernières années sans
aboutir il nous faudra procéder
rapidement mais avec méthode à des choix
qui dans ce domaine essentiel pour la
souveraineté de notre pays ne peuvent
être fait sans l'état si l'on fait la
synthèse des déclarations de lionel
jospin ici au bourget et jeudi dernier à
l'assemblée nationale on a déjà quelques
pistes
le gouvernement ne fait pas privatiser
thompson mais il veut en faire un pôle
de l'industrie militaire française il ne
voit pas non plus d'avenir en dehors des
regroupements européens lionel jospin a
aussi repris à son compte l'idée d'alain
juppé de jacques chirac d'une fusion
aérospatiale d'assaut le marianne sorte
de table c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre tout à l'heure je vous assure
me semble aller dans le bon sens
absolument
on veut pas faire une défense en ce
mariage je ne pense pas la coloc des
privatisations
c'est à dire pas que l'aérospatiale sera
privatisée
avec dassault sinon nous n'accepterons
pas ce soir finalement à la veille de la
clôture du salon du bourget on n'est pas
beaucoup plus fixés sur l'avenir de
l'industrie aéronautique et militaire
française on sait seulement que le
gouvernement souhaite des regroupements
et des coopérations européennes et qu'il
est a priori hostile aux privatisations